Hi, I'm Eric Grundhauser,
community editor at Atlas Obscura.
And today I'm at Syndaver,
home of the synthetic
cadaver, where, whoa!
Operating out of an unassuming office park
in Tampa, Florida,
Syndaver is in the business
of making bodies.
Syndaver was founded in the early 2000s
by non-medical doctor
Christopher Sakezles,
originally in an effort
to find an alternative
to the sad practice of using sedated cats
in medical training.
Finding the available
anatomical training tools
cold, mechanical, and
nothing like the real thing,
Sakezles developed a unique
formula for fake tissue
that's little more than a
special mixture of water,
salt, and other ingredients.
The company now makes cats,
dogs, humans, and more,
all totally synthetic,
and uncannily authentic.
Believe me: We went there,
and it was visceral.
For as sci-fi a concept as
chemical flesh might be,
the process of creating
the company's cadavers
is more Frankenstein than "Westworld."
Sure, there are 3D
printers running off bones
and prototypes in hard plastic,
but almost every component
of Syndaver's products
are assembled by teams of artisans.
Sculptors, tailors, painters,
and other creative types
working together to create cadavers
that look like they were made by robots.
The facility even smells
like an art studio.
The scent of alginate, clay,
and other unidentifiable
chemical materials
hit you from the second
you open the doors.
Throughout Syndaver's facility,
workers were hunched over tables,
meticulously building
biology from scratch.
Teams of two were busy assembling
molded muscle and tissue,
sewing away like gruesome tailors.
They stitch the parts together
using waxed dental floss.
(Mint. Never cinnamon.)
Down the hall, Syndaver's
primary veterinary advisor
was intubating a canine model
to show how they could inflate the lungs.
This high level of artisanal care
is all in service of what they
call the "empathy effect,"
that innate emotional connection
to other living creatures,
which other training devices often forgo
in favor of a cold efficiency.
And this handcrafted
realism doesn't come cheap.
Even the least expensive
Syndaver human cadaver
costs around $45,000,
which might seem somewhat
crazy for a training aid,
but compared to real human cadavers,
it's actually pretty inexpensive.
Cadavers require iron-clad
approval documentation,
dedicated infrastructure and facilities
to store and handle
them, and then of course
there's the shelf life.
Flesh cadavers aren't exactly reusable.
In the long run, a Syndaver cadaver,
with its replaceable parts
and nearly limitless shelf life,
has the potential to save
schools millions of dollars
in infrastructure costs alone.
Each model can also be customized
to various purposes and
levels of complexity.
They can be made to
breathe or bleed as needed,
and Syndaver's models are now finding uses
outside of the world of medical training,
including as military and
ballistics testing dummies.
When we look to the
future of human simulacra,
we tend to think that
the next quantum leap
towards lifelike synthetic biology
will come from the world of robotics,
but Syndaver's focus on recreating
the sensual experience of interacting
with a formerly living thing
might just be a next step.
They might not walk around,
but they look like they could.
And time will tell whether
Syndaver's products
will end up taking all of the jobs
from hard-working flesh cadavers,
but in the meantime it sure is fascinating
to watch them try.
Hey, thanks for watching.
Be sure to click to subscribe
and see more videos from Atlas Obscura.
And down in the comments,
tell us what unusual factory
you'd like to see us explore next.